l'architecture des années 1930 à silaos
vers 1815 on découvre dans le cirque de
Cilaos des sources d'eau chaude
présentant les mêmes caractéristiques
que celle de Vichy une station thermale
voit le jour quelques années plus tard
après la création d'une route entre la
côte et le cirque en 1932 si la hausse
attire de plus en plus de curistes en
1934 pour encourager le développement du
tourisme le Conseil Général décide de
créer un hôtel mise en chantier en 1935
il est achevé l'année suivante avec ses
21 chambres le Grand Hôtel et le premier
exemple d'architecture hôtelière à la
Réunion
les réunions des fortunées qui viennent
prendre les eaux à Cilaos construisaient
aussi des maisons de villégiature
notamment le long du chemin conduisant
au Sentier des termes
tout comme l'architecture publique et
religieuse de cette époque à la Réunion
ces maisons adoptent les canaux
esthétiques du style à leur en vigueur
en Europe l'Art Déco
parfois ajouté à des maisons plus
anciennes ou intégrées d'office aux
maisons construites dans les années 30
les façades présentent tous les
attributs de ce style notamment les
Boeing
ces élégantes partis en saillie abritent
souvent une varangue fermée
particulièrement agréable pendant les
mois les plus frais de l'année
les plus beaux exemples d'architecture
des années 1930 à la Réunion se trouve
de nos jours encore à silhouse mais
aussi à la Rivière Saint-Louis et à
Saint-Denis